[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui on va parler ordinateur on
va parler de dell on a derrière ici
voyez ces marques et bains douches
voilà c'est un faux ami en réalité on va
pas du tout aux bains douches pas mettre
un peignoir aujourd'hui on va pas aller
se baigner
on va aller voir la gamme d'ordinateurs
portables de dell
vous allez voir ce qu'ils sont vraiment
sympas on en reparlera plus tard ont été
ses produits mais pour l'instant on va
en immersion on va découvrir
donc là on est chez dell avec bettina
walia bon toi tu t'occupes tu me disais
de la stratégie du pin galant talent
exceptionnel
j'ai retenu tu m'as dit à 30 secondes
c'est très facile pour moi alors l idée
est ce que tu peux me faire faire un
tour un peu de toujours on va essayer en
solutions laptop même expliqué me
présentais pour qui quoi comment ce
qu'on peut faire tout ça tout ça
donc en fait chez dell s'est pas c'est
pas compliqué la gamme 1 et se divisent
pour la gamme quand tu meurs en trois
séries pour les inspirons dans le 3000
5000 et 7000 évidemment clairement le
3000 s'adresse à une clientèle qui veut
juste faire de l'internet avec des specs
assez légère
la série 5000 on évolue un petit peu on
a plus de spect dessus et on bascule
vers des offres de prix alors entre 400
et 700 euros
et puis après on a une gamme 7000 qui
elle en fait va amener un châssis en
termes de design beaucoup plus
sophistiqué du travail est plus
travaillé et évidemment des specs un peu
plus évolué voilà comment leur seule
chance est mille fois ici les super mini
en fait les sucres a faim c'est un
produit convertibles donc tort tactile
avec une qualité d'écran exceptionnelle
ses amis hd et là dessus en fait on a un
nouveau metal et une nouvelle couleur
café chouette en fait et
qui en fait nous permet d'adresser une
clientèle qui a besoin de se balader
l'ultra mobilité avec que du ssd à
l'intérieur donc c'est rapide et une
qualité d'écran exceptionnel donc là
dessus un peu vert de la question on
colle aux dés
ah oui alors de toute façon oui tout ça
c'est un écran qhd et qui peut également
faire de la vidéo pour la vidéo et tous
à tous les usages très multimédia il est
ultra fin donc je suis pas fou regarder
vraiment alors la mode en ce moment
c'est de dire que les produits non plus
de bordures donc c'est exactement le cas
de celui ci on met des produits 13
pouces dans des châssis de 11 donc voilà
on les goûts plus en plus petit plus en
plus léger et mimi alors les produits se
déclinent en différentes tailles d'écran
d'un clavier ça commence par le fesf
pouces oui on a 10 14 ans n'a dû 15 et
on a dû vous fait d'accord même les 17
ça marche encore le 17 à bagan lamelle
du dc reconvertibles chez nous on est
jeune douce est compatible vertige si tu
veux regarder la vidéo un film n'importe
quoi c'est génial tu as une grande
taille d'écran filtre en plus ce qui
peut travailler
de sucer des processeurs core i7 donc
c'est assez performant on peut avoir des
cartes graphiques si on veut j'ai
reproduit à cibl polyvalent hockey
[Applaudissements]
ça qu'on sait que tu petit change tout
le temps là c'est comme ça non c'est
compris comme ça
[Applaudissements]
l'idée du temps et quand ils arrivent
ils arrivent après on a une gamme qu'on
appelle xps 5 et nos gains très haut de
gamme qui est un produit qui est un peu
à cheval entre usage
on va dire qu'on est super et
professionnels donc là il ya aucun
compromis signés en matériel ni ans perd
en rien du tout c'est un produit avec
des matériaux très sophistiqué en est
sûr de carbone du métal de l'alu doré
différence entre la gamme xps une gamme
inspirons qu'on avait coûté alors
vraiment comprendre les surtout surtout
en fait on va voir dans la qualité du du
châssis d'accord matériaux qu'on utilise
pour fabriquer l'aluminium dans le test
là on a de lui carbone qu'on abatte
sorbonne les ordres voilà mais plus le
jeu est exactement le robuste mais très
robuste les autres sont robustes aussi
me suis dit il à la robustesse et la
légèreté en plus et décline aussi en
deux formats 13 et 15
et aussi on a un châssis 15 pouces qui
convertit je sais pas si c'est celui ci
celui-ci sympa cas et on a un converti
[Rires]
incassable
donc ok ensuite ensuite on a ça c'est
propre à l on est assez fort en gaming
le lyonnais on a élargi cette année
notre gamme c'est à dire que on était
très connu sur notre gamme alienware est
un peu notre bébé notre marque qui
bondissent on vend du navy ouais c'est
notre standard gaming alors évidemment
nos châssis gaming sont là là c'est
notamment à 15 coups on a dû certes on a
dû 13 6 mais lassé des produits vont
avec des cannes est très possible
on a même de la celi est survenu sur
nous on a des écrans jusqu'à 160 hertz
enfin bon on est sur des produits très
évolués hardcore gaming et c'est ok et
on a aussi en décliner maintenant
l'offre cette année sur des séries tels
jets gaming donc c'est le big bang c'est
en gros on va retrouver avant de mourir
je vais exactement éventuellement donc
on commence par une série g 3g 5
et ça ce sont des produits qui aussi
offre d'esprit des possibilités
techniques si sophistiquées
le g3 permet d'avoir une entrée de gamme
mx les les gaming entrée de gamme avec
des 10 50 des 10 60
donc avec le g5 comme sur l'a10 la santé
avec des processeurs aussi plus
sophistiqué c'est un produit il ya une
ventilation enfin il ya tout à une
arborescence à l'intérieur qui permet de
faire du gaming et la machine
il ya une ventilation qui sait aussi
pour permettre aux présentes de se
refroidir
ok ça c'est l'argument guillemets et
voilà donc là on est sûr g3 g5 et
alienware au kenya et alors j'ai vu que
vous auriez corner un peu dur au titre
ouais effectivement la battue face à des
produits plus gros oui alors moi je ne
sais pas lesquels ce n est pas encore
été dans la pièce mais si ces nouveaux
strauss les produits tout en déliés pour
la bureautique pour pour la toute petite
entreprise voilà ils peuvent
effectivement aujourd'hui faire
l'acquisition d'un produit vostro qu'ils
déclinent d'un 13 pouces jusqu'à 1 15 14
et 15 courses ok on a de la chance là
aujourd'hui on a une cuisine qui est
juste incroyable rue des mois cette
large
j'adore montre un petit peu les endroits
comme ça parce que c'est dans votre
comportement exceptionnel on est dans
une espèce de l'oft loft et une cuisine
diouf fou furieux
on a de quoi boire un coup de quoi
manger un goût des petites minières vive
pour les plutôt pas mal
on a aussi une gamme d'écrans donc qui
est très bien on a des produits très
très faim l'appareil dans les écrans le
design aujourd'hui contribuent beaucoup
au rôle en deux sets de 7 de ce segment
on voit des produits de plus en plus fin
avec des bordures très très fine et des
qualités dalle aussi il se perfectionne
de plus en plus donc ça aussi ça fait
partie de l'offre oden donc on n'a pas
une solution très complète pc écrans
gaming donc ça aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qui est propre à la fantaisie
d'elle d'ailleurs la plus grande
celui ci ont possible dans la machine
dans le dans le domaine de la vie quoi
ok cool
bon voilà pour 7 et 22 d'elle
aujourd'hui on parlera de dell bien
évidemment très prochainement dans une
prochaine vidéo on va tester les
produits il ya une grosse actu aussi là
dessus donc je vous invite à faire une
chose c'est bien évidemment rester
connecté parce que on va suivre tout ça
on va tester on aura démontré
donc je vous invite à faire une seule
chose comme d'habitude c'est à vous
abonner et un resté collé
[Musique]